In teenagers,
either historical,
median cartel data,
Pablo Escobar has an idea,
basically he had a vision,
suddenly have a dream,
and that was to turn Columbia into a
narco state,
the country where the governments and
all public institutions would be
directly controlled by drug trafficking.
Such was his commitment.
That's in 1982 as I think you probably
know,
Pablo Escobar himself,
one of the most important mobsters in
all of history,
gained a seat at the Columbian Chamber
of Representatives and it's important to
bear in mind that it's one thing for the
mafia to buy or bribe a politician and
quite another for them to hold all the
power directly.
Can you imagine a country where the
police,
the army,
all administrative officials,
and even the courts themselves as well,
timidly under the direct orders of drug
dealers.
Of course,
if Pablo Escobar's vision had panned
out,
Columbia wouldn't certainly have much
higher levels of drug production and
exports,
but the median cartel itself would
become untouchable.
Invincible.
He would've gained complete impunity to
do and undo whatever he wanted at.
Well,
fortunately Pablo Escobar never managed
to carry out his dream.
However,
today,
three decades later,
it looks like his dream is now being
realized,
but this time we're not talking about
Columbia.
We're talking about Venezuela,
Columbia dictum,
wounded,
seeing grapples,
Columbiana,
Archean minutes with dealer.
Yeah,
Cmo that apparently the four characters
you're looking at right now,
don't only control the country,
they are also the leaders of an
international crime and drug trafficking
network.
Of course,
we're talking about Nicolas Maduro,
the president of Venezuela,
dios data Qbo,
the powerful presidents of the National
Constituent Assembly who already rank as
the strongest man in the regime,
and Tarek,
El Assami format,
vice presidents and current Minister of
Industry and national production whose
personal fortune according to dea
calculations,
surpasses the $3,000,000,000 mark.
And the fourth is Nestor Rivera,
Minister of internal affairs,
justice and peace.
Who could top it all off.
Was the previous national accounts,
an architect's office director.
Well,
everything indicates that these four
people are leading the transformation of
Venezuela into a narco state.
Listen Up.
Mafia takes control.
Venezuela is in shreds.
Hunger is increasing,
inflation is out of control,
and hundreds of thousands of people are
fleeing the country.
Even hospitals don't have basic supplies
like medicine,
analytical equipment,
or pastors.
There's such a huge mess that the vsa
itself,
the Venezuelan state owned oil company
with the most reserves in the world is
bankrupt.
Consider
this to this day,
Pdvsa has many embargoed waters.
There's in order to sell the
increasingly dwindling Venezuelan oil,
it's beginning to resort to do tricks
and techniques used by Hollywood movie
style smugglers.
For example,
since Venezuelan oil companies are at
risk of being confiscated to settle all
outstanding debts on the oil,
they transport pdvsa has begun to
transfer oil from its ships,
do other ships with the Cuban flag out
at sea.
These ships are then responsible for
taking the crude oil to its destination,
thus avoiding being seized because folks
in Venezuela,
practically everything that has value
has been or is being looted.
Corruption has reached almost every
corner of the country,
so the Bolivarian Revolution promised
prosperity.
What they forgot to clarify is that all
that prosperity would only be for a few
for the friends of the revolution.
Of course.
Don't believe me?
Well,
take a look at this.
Many regime members promote and lead
operations for gas contraband to
southern Brazil and Colombia.
They are also mostly responsible for
food and medicine contrabands,
which the state buys and then sells on
the black market.
They have looted public accounts and
tens of billions of dollars have
disappeared from the government and from
the PDVSA in Venezuela.
Even the central banks,
US dollars have been looted.
Yeah,
you really did hear that,
right?
That allow me to explain this.
One of the first things that the Chavez
regime did was implement a rigid
exchange control.
They fixed,
for example,
the official exchange between the
boulevard and the US dollar to a rate
that had nothing to do with the numbers
on the street.
That way the government's friends could
access US dollars with just a handful of
Bolivares bolivares.
That gives it the country's current
hyper inflation knob.
Now with practically nothing,
the minivan was so well perfected that
it is estimated that 20 percent of all
imports declared in recent years have
been completely false operations that
were done for the sole purpose of
obtaining dollars at the official
exchange rate and then to save them in
foreign accounts.
And this is important because according
to estimates,
we could be talking about a theft of
more than a hundred billion dollars and
of course be Dvsa,
hasn't escaped this plunder.
A group of companies lent seven point 2
billion boulevard to PD vsa,
which when exchange at the black market
rate would be about $42,
million dollars,
but when exchange at the official rate
would become approximately $600,
million dollars which were deposited in
an account in Malta,
CSR but t's Venezuelan journalists,
but of course sins,
no more can be squeezed out of the
country.
The regime Johnson sought a new
alternative source of income.
Put up your faith,
put up your faith.
I said,
no,
no.
Well,
they look
it for you.
So no,
turning into a narco state
of drug dealers in Venezuela isn't new
med.
Has however evolved and I want to
explain for years,
Colombian cartels trying to use routes
through Venezuela to distribute that
product.
Then of course to do so,
they began bing,
policemen,
national guard members,
high officials,
et Cetera.
These people would then turn a blind
eye.
This was the first stage as it works.
Dealer's got to know the land batter and
figured out who they could trust and who
they couldn't,
so they moved into the second stage of
things,
which was something like,
all right,
now that we have a deal,
I'll give you some more money,
but you don't only look away.
You've also got to protect me and
transport my merchandise.
And this second stage was implemented
later.
Many Colombian mobsters realized that
given the enormous pressure that they
had from the Colombian government and
the dea,
that'd be safer in Venezuela.
So at the beginning of the 21st century,
that's precisely what happens.
Any of these sinister merchants moved
their operation centers from Columbia to
Venezuela and that's when they started
to closely collaborate with the
authorities there.
And I mean really
sleep
say,
what do you think the Venezuelan
government did them?
Well,
and then 2005,
they decided to expel the dea from
Venezuela and territory and suspends
their agreements to monitor knockout
flights.
Therefore,
Venezuelan and territory became a kind
of refuge for drug trafficking in the
United States.
Could no longer keep track of them.
They're pretty fantastic for them,
isn't it?
Of course,
in exchange for getting rid of the
United States,
they have to pay a modest commission.
The regime johns,
they needed to live off something.
Right?
Well,
that was the third stage.
Hold on.
One moment,
hit because that's how we got to the
fourth and last stage,
which is where we're at,
right?
This was going well so well.
In fact.
So there's plenty of the Bolivarian
Revolution.
Really.
Leaders asked themselves a question.
We have the government,
the police,
the army,
and did a lot of resources.
Why on earth should we share anything
with the Colombians sold?
Whoever else?
Let's those couples that are
Columbiana.
Archean minutes.
Wait,
sorry.
Do you know what happened then?
Well,
the Venezuelan authorities began
arresting all of the drug traffickers,
so you didn't want to cooperate with
them by giving that route says well as
their distribution business to them.
That's how people such as Maximiliano
Bonnier,
AK,
if an NCR know the chief of the office,
Heck Taught Harnaman,
we Terago Aka Martin Yan Os Diego Perez,
Aka Diego restaurant,
and Daniel baret rubber re run naked.
All Loco fell.
All of them were found in the list of
most significant traffic,
so everything
indicates that right now in Venezuela,
even though there are tons of criminal
groups operating in the area,
the government giants hold the ultimate
control and control to characters like
del Dotto,
Kobe allegedly the most important leader
of the cartel,
the cartel formed by the leaders of the
Bolivarian government's.
The Venezuelan people suffer under
corrupt politicians who tighten their
grip overpower while lining their own
pockets.
We are imposing costs on figures like
Dios,
Datto Cabello,
who exploited their official positions
to engage in narcotics trafficking,
money laundering,
and Basil Mint of state funds and other
corrupt activities.
US Treasury Secretary Steven mentioned
in fact one of his own personal
assistance,
at least me Salazar,
fled Venezuela in 2014 with the help of
the dea and his statement couldn't be
more forceful in addition to providing
evidence on the organization's
operation.
He stated the mystic Dubay presidents of
the National Constituent Assembly gives
direct orders on the rips and the
departure of boats loaded with
prohibited substances,
and he's not the only one.
Testimonies are accumulating in the
officers of the DEA,
for example.
Those will lead Mac lead statements from
when he was arrested in Columbia in
2011.
Mccullough was one of the most powerful
drug traffickers in Venezuela,
for example,
you controlled Puerto Cabezas,
which according to the dea was the exit
point for most of the narcotics
distributed from the country.
Well,
after his arrest,
he had declared with great detail that
he had done business with several dozens
of Venezuelan generals,
high level government officials such as
Henry Rangel Silva,
who was later named minister of Defense,
or Hugo Carvajal,
former army intelligence director who
supposedly paid him $50,000 a week,
which is certainly a nice salary.
He also claims to a financed one of Hugo
Chavez campaigns in exchange for
concessions in Puerto Conveyor.
With all these relationships,
it's easy to understand how in November
2016,
a friend and tune your Campo Flores and
Francisco Flores to freight us to have
the Venezuelan first ladies,
nephews were convicted in a New York
court conspiring to traffic hundreds of
kilos of narcotics and folks,
according to current estimates,
the business in Venezuela at wingstop
growing between 15 and 20 percent of all
the cocaine that moves in the world
every year passes through this country.
And not only that,
as apparently the number of laboratories
is also raising a great deal.
Of course,
the giants of the Bolivarian Revolution.
The money to keep the structures of
repression loyal,
the army,
the police,
the national guard or so in exchange for
working in Venezuela,
the different criminal groups based
there from the mafia to the
paramilitaries and the Colombian
gorillas support the regime and since
there's good business,
Maduro and company are still filling
that pockets.
Unfortunately,
the consequences of all of this are
terrible for one looting.
All public resources has led the country
to ruin ends.
On top of that,
it's fueling an enormous amount of
violence.
See,
according to data from the Venezuelan
violence observatory,
2017,
there were 89 homicides per 100,000
inhabitants in the country that is more
than 26,000 people who lost their lives
violently.
The
twitter has become the most dangerous
country in all of Latin America.
And the situation in some areas like
Caracas is even worse.
The country's homicide rate skyrocketed
in 2017 to 130 people 100,000
inhabitants.
Meanwhile,
members of the government,
I'll taking advantage of the situation
and developing fortunes which they're
using to buy properties all over the
world from the Dominican Republic to
Madrid.
Indeed Madrid is a city to which not
only thousands of Venezuelans fleeing
the disaster are arriving,
but also many of the relatives of the
Solos,
cartel,
bosses and other high position members,
loyal to the revolution.
Going to now sometimes find myself
sitting in restaurants in Madrid right
next to people who might.
I wouldn't feel comfortable,
ever seen CADAC Leopoldo Lopez Gill,
father of Leopoldo Lopez,
a leading opposition politician who has
been kept under house arrest in Cadac
us.
Unfortunately,
the bolivarian regime has founded it's
best ally in drug dealing though to fill
their pockets and to keep that power in
shorter viewer.
For now,
this is just how things are,
so I really hope you found this video
interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe.
Also,
don't forget to check it.
Our friends at the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine.
Also,
of course,
this channel is possible because of our
patriot and our patrons on that
platform.
Please do consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always,
thank you for watching
if you can,
but a lot more hierarchical,
but the low noise.